you know also
when you want to take a take a toilet
you know sometimes you got to worry
about oh my bag my stuff's here i don't
want to pack it all up
in japan i know i know but also any
other country i'd be like yeah but like
i've got to do so also yeah but it's a
bit different when we go to the toilet
when you go to the toilet because you
take an hour and you're at the toilet
and and i feel like you're tempting fate
you're really pushing japan's limits on
what will be stolen yeah it probably
won't be but now
i'm five minutes i'm in and out it's
fine nobody made a big deal but also i
also like being able to fully immerse
myself in the toilet experience and i
feel like i can't do that in the public
toilet you know what i mean
i can't i've never been speechless i
can't enjoy
experience i want to go to the toilet
comfortably
i i agree with you in terms of [ __ ]
right oh my god we're we're [ __ ]
talking about shits again
number two in public because i need my
own private space
you can't go to the toilet in public
number two why i like it's it's like a
last resort right what what why because
because i want my own private space
right i wanna i want what are you doing
are you [ __ ] on me he's making art
what are you doing
okay okay okay i don't want a time limit
to how long i need to sit on the toilet
again i don't give a [ __ ] when i wave
someone i understand sometimes you you
have to take the time you take yeah i'll
complain about it someone takes ten
minutes of [ __ ] yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
he can take him ten minutes to take a
[ __ ] well he doesn't want to be
complained about that's the point i'm
not gonna
feel good i'm gonna mutter under my
breath when i sit down with a [ __ ]
actually i don't want to feel pressured
you know i i i hate it when i feel like
just don't feel pressured just don't you
don't feel pressure you can't it's not a
see-through door you can't see the
[ __ ] line you're [ __ ] you and
you're going to brush the artist when
he's making his heart all right
we've all been there we've all been
there you're [ __ ] desperate for the
toilet and you're like you're [ __ ]
searching for any public toilet you can
maybe you're in a starbucks maybe you're
in a train station right and you go to
this order and there's just this one guy
who's just taking three millennials as
much as
you every time it's not nothing [ __ ]
here i don't want to be that guy that's
why i'm just like no i'm doing it
oh there's gone again i i want to have a
comfortable experience and i understand
that comes it might take a little more
time than i'd like right i understand
that comes with the fact that someone
else is going to want a comfortable
experience i don't have to wait i don't
give a [ __ ] literally i don't i will i
will wait to give that [ __ ] i i will
wait the five minutes to ten minutes
whatever it be yeah yeah i'll be like
[ __ ] say why taste like but you know at
the end of the day i don't give a [ __ ]
you have some very i mean
what a big man here what a big man like
you have some really [ __ ] weird
toilet habits
okay so before before we start recording
kind of kind of goes into the toilet
joey yeah right and he goes
do you sit down when you pee and i'm
just like
what i'm mixing
i do do you have a penis is it isn't
that isn't the whole point of being a
man is so you can get your god-given
right to pee standing up and you choose
to sit down i sometimes sit down
whenever oh wrong oh my god bro i got
like big ass cheeks sometimes it's just
it's like it's [ __ ] bidets have
rotted your guy's mind no no no no no
no no no no no hear me out the reason
why i sometimes sit down to pee is
because when you're standing up you're
contracting right now or for one you
can't check him it's literally five
seconds ten seconds
no no but like for me what it is is that
sometimes i sit down to pee because
sometimes i don't want to [ __ ] clean
my mess
yeah you know you might you might be in
a toilet when you pee in a toilet you
you can't guarantee no splashbox yeah
exactly we're talking about someone who
cleans the toilets in his own house i
don't want to clean that [ __ ] when
you're wearing shorts and you pee right
if it's like if there's like a 30
centimeter difference between where your
or your pp's and the toilet there's
gonna be splashbacks yeah if you're
wearing shorts you'll feel it on your
legs exactly so when you're going into a
toilet and there's a urinal there do you
just sometimes go to
the public the public too yeah if it's a
problem yeah because sometimes you want
to sit down yeah sometimes i've been
walking around for so long i'm just
[ __ ] exhausted bro
there are no benches in japan right so
the next best thing is a toilet this is
the most unoptimized way to go to the
toilet ever like that you should be
against this you're literally spending
more energy to sit down pee than it is
just like two birds one stone it's like
what he has to talk about
and he gets the city i pee i'm not i
don't immediately get back up i'm on my
phone for like five minutes i'm just
scrolling this is the best phone
you're criticizing him for taking an
hour to [ __ ]
you take five minutes to pee no not
actually five minutes but like i i play
my phone a little bit they play some
angry birds you know some cut the rope
you know the classics i've got doodle
jumps
you know how it is you know but no you
actually genuinely take 30 minutes of
[ __ ] i don't think that's yeah i i i
actually genuinely i haven't we get to
the point in this office where i
legitimately go where's god we go
and we realize he's been gone for 30
minutes did he go to the shops or
something no he's taking a [ __ ] okay but
like i'm actually i'm i'm not just
sitting there for no reason okay i don't
know what part of this just take can you
explain which aspect takes 30 minutes
are you performing like alchemy in there
like why is it taking so long i know
some sometimes like i just feel
uncomfortable if i don't feel completely
empty like like like like i need to feel
completely empty before i feel
comfortable stopping the process right
what are you talking about sometimes
you're just not going to empty out man
you just got to get on with it you're
going to be sitting back you're
literally going to be sitting there all
day just go back completely fine with
that
have you not considered taking like you
don't have a limit to how many shits you
can take a day you know like you can if
you you take a [ __ ] you get up and you
go oh i'll just come back about an hour
later you're like oh i'm a bit full
again you can't go back yeah but unlike
video games you can pause
why do you have to like why do you have
to be like this is the only [ __ ] i can
take for the day i'm going to empty out
when i try
like like it's like you're not a dog
you've nerfed yourself you've nerfed
yourself i nerfed myself i i have that
feeling right where i'm not fully empty
i'm like
shogun on get on with the dead man i'll
come back later in fact i think like two
to three shits a day on average yeah me
too me too just because like i know like
i'm just like in and out if i'm still
full it's all right i'll be back in a
minute you can tell within like two
pushes if it's common enough i don't
know not like you don't restrain
you're depraving a good [ __ ]
experience bro you're okay i'm sorry
your ass muscle is probably the
strongest [ __ ] thing it exists the
amount you've probably worked that thing
out is probably insane i'm probably
crushed someone's head with your anus
man jesus christ
you know i'm i'm i'm a [ __ ] say
sometimes the shits are the highlights
of the day like like like like some
sometimes you just need a [ __ ] escape
from you why are you okay like are your
days okay i want days like [ __ ] good
man
are you kidding me sometimes you just
need to escape from your man cave you
just need to go on your twitter he's
like like i just imagined it he's just
eight hours in the starbucks [ __ ]
vain bursting in his head he's like
i gotta go and [ __ ] but i gotta go home
i can't do it here it's gonna take one
hour
this is the black hole is forming in his
[ __ ]
like i will do anything to like to like
hold it so i can so i can get back home
and just get in my comfortable space
right you have okay okay like some some
of like
some of the best ideas i swear to god
some like human human civilization would
be like 50 less civilized if
people didn't have a space to [ __ ] in
comfortably i swear to god some of the
best ideas come on the toilet i'm i'm
not [ __ ] crazy okay god listen if you
spend a majority of your day on the
toilet yes most of your ideas are gonna
be on the toilet so that's
that's where that's coming from
what i'm saying is the toilet is just a
comfortable place with zero distractions
you're just free with your own thoughts
and the only place that really that the
only place you're in it sounds like you
voluntarily put yourself in prison for
30 hours also it's like like how much
more chaotic is your like other
explosions happening in your room like
what
like how much more how much more
relaxing could it be compared to your
own room i'm sorry it's it's it's like
there's there's two spots that you just
can't take away from me my [ __ ]
toilet where i can [ __ ] at my shower
where can i where i can take 40 minute
showers it's 40 minute showers this
month's morning routine you know you
know there's influences you're like i
get up at 5 00 a.m i'm gonna do all this
[ __ ] god's like i get up at five pm i
take a shower seven 7am i take a [ __ ]
9am i'm ready to work
honestly
literally it's like interesting honestly
after after that 40 minutes you have the
most productive hour of your life man i
swear to [ __ ] god
40-minute showers you know africa would
be a first world country if you didn't
take showers that long
jesus christ